hello everyone today was the first day
of the World Cup and interestingly the
world champion Magnus Carlsen is also
playing in the World Cup and after he
wins this event he will challenge
himself for the title just kidding of
course but it is interesting that the
world champion is playing in the World
Cup and I saw pretty much the top twenty
games and there weren't really that many
surprises some people managed to draw
games against some of the top ten
grandmasters mostly the favorites won
their games but the biggest upset of
round one was definitely the Canadian
Grandmaster butter Sam Bowie crushing a
China superstar Yee and it would it's
definitely a beautiful game it's a
miniature I think it's 24 moves I will
put the interview with the butter
somewhere in the description below so
you can also check that out
so yeah let's let's see this game butter
some work of Canada is white and the way
you of China is black and oh yeah
although butter somewhere was originally
from Russia now he has Canadian
citizenship and he also won the 2011
Canadian championship after a playoff
against Eric Hanson ok proceeding to the
game we have Knight to f3 by somewhere
when I 12 6 c4 e6 Knight to c3 we have B
5 B 4 so the Queens gambit declined
Bishop to b4 we have g3 so some Catalan
we have castles Bishop to G - D captures
on c4 and some wave castles I will have
a Knight to c6 a3 attacking the bishop
Bishop d7 and now e4 and here we place
the knight Knight to a5 preparing maybe
Knight to b3 also adding protection to
this c4 pawn and well simply the
preparing to push on the Queen side we
have Bishop to e3 by some wave to rook
to b8 preparing to put b5 22 now wait
does push b5
we have rook a to be 1 and the bishop to
b7 attack
that eforp on we have 95 now the bishop
from g2 is defending on e4 and we have a
six and here this nice thief I've moved
to defend this efore pawn but this is
also preparing to push this G phone as a
Jeep on on the Kings side so he does he
pushes G for preparing g5 when he plays
Knight to e8 and here we have d5 and
this is a good move it opens up this
bishop here so it improves his influence
it kind of stops this Knight from going
into the game we are c6 so way you
capture Z captors on d5 we have Knight
captures on d5 and now Knight to d6 and
here we have g5 by somewhere we have
basic capture Sun d5 rope captors on d5
and c6 rook to d1 quinta c7 and now
Queen to h5 and this is a this is a very
tricky move Queen to h5 as it seems like
when you can capture this efore point
but if you would were to capture this an
e4 pawn would the night
so if Bishop captures and I think Queen
captures this knight on e5 then if he
runs into Bishop f4 and this is well
this is very unpleasant somewhere would
be threatening some very nasty
discoveries after after this night jumps
first for example to g6 or even if the
Queen moves the rope would still be
attacked and here after this Queen h5 o
way actually try it tries a dirty trick
the trick somewhere
he plays g6 we have Queen to h6 and now
why he thinks that he can grab this pawn
and he plays Knight captures on e4 and
now if if somewhere would would play
Bishop therefore he would run into
Bishop captures and g5 has now the queen
is on h6 so this tactic works and the
bishop is protected with the night so
the Queen obviously can capture and if
beta captures Bishop then simply Knight
captures Bishop and after Queen captures
Bishop f6 and this is much better for
black but after Knight captures on e4
this was actually some woods idea all
along he decided to sack
fyz this pawn and he plays Knight to d7
a threatening of course the threat is
Bishop captures night and after well the
night has to be protected or moved and
Knight to f6 is the real threat so
threatening mate on h7 and if Bishop
captures pawn captures and then there's
a checkmate on g7 so of course way he
plays Knight to d6 and now the city is
no longer possible if somewhere would
play Knight to f6 check then captures
pawn captures and he is a threatening
mate and g7 but Knight f5 simply defends
everything with a temple on the Queen as
well so after Knight to d6 way he played
Bishop to h3 now defending his Knight
there are only seven we have and this is
the the most critical moment of the game
this is the point of no return and well
it's pretty pretty hard to defend
actually way you played rook F to d8 now
attacking this night and it well the
only square for the knight appears to be
either c5 or or e5 but this this night
doesn't matter because some wolf plays
rook to d4 and it's in this position
that way you resigned the game as he
realizes there is no defense against
rook to h4 I have to rope to h4 black
can't defend and it's really hard to
find a move here for example if if he
even tries to stop this by Bishop
captures than g5
for example Bishop captures and g5 then
simply the Bishop captures and g5 and
this and the threat of rock page 4 is
still here and even if he doesn't have
to route to d4 for example if rook
captures here then simply rotate for
immediately and this is completely over
there there is no defense against this
black can't try to play for example with
f5 but simply Queen captures on h7 came
to f8 Queen captures on g6 and well this
this will be this would be torture for
black
so after this
- the four move this is moved 24 away
you resign the game and it's it's very
nice that it did so this game can be
considered a miniature and a beautiful
game by the Canadian Grandmaster butter
Sambu F so yeah and I think this is the
this is the biggest upset of round one
and we'll see what around - brings us so
yeah I do hope you enjoy the game like I
said you can check out the interview
with Grandmaster butter Samba in the
description below and I would like to
thank James bolt our on Lucas and such
and Chenoa for a contribution to my
channel I really appreciate it and yeah
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I'll see you soon